evening everybody
welcome to the developed committee 11th
of January 2018
before we get started should we be
required to evacuate the building would
you please leave via the nearest
available exit to the chamber our
assembly point will be in the public
carpark at the side of the Civic suite
please do not delay your evacuation to
collect any belongings please do not
return into the building until give them
permission to do so Bar Council staff
please note that this meeting will be
audio recorded and if you have a mobile
please put it on silent thank you
welcome to our visitors tonight there
will be I'm sure some bits of the
meeting that you agree with some bits
that you don't agree with but
nevertheless there isn't any part for
public contribution to the meeting
unless you've already registered to
speak as we have over here so if you
wouldn't mind respecting that as we go
through thank you item 1 apologies for
absence have been received in the office
from councillor Steptoe is being
substituted by councillor cut more
councillor Shaw who's been substituted
by Council looks Gail
councillor Mel who's been substituted
from by accounts for sparing accounts
the Stanley and a substitution of
counselor mrs. hoi by councillor mrs.
Mason there anymore thank you very much
non-members attending I note councillor
mrs. Hoyt counts the mr. Hoyt councillor
mr. Mason and councillor mrs lammle item
4 minutes of the meeting held on the
14th of December 2017 when you were
happy for me to sign those as a correct
and accurate record of that meeting
councillor hawk way
yes I do have an issue in relation to
the minutes at the last meeting of the
development committee there was a matter
which was raised in relation to an
application and under advice from the
the chairman and also the planning
officers this was informed that was not
part form part of the particular
application
that information has since been found
out to be incorrect and masa could have
been dealt with at the committee for
which a communal community might lose
out funding for a particular project on
I hope that this doesn't happen but it
would seem that there are situations
where by planning officers haven't been
part of the whole process of a
particular application where it's been
pass from one one person to another and
during the course of this some
information seems to be of dismissed or
lost and not been part of the report
what I would say is that perhaps that we
should be not quite so dismissive of
some members questions because they
might be relevant or to a particular
application and like in this particular
incidents are therefore would like my
comments related to the minutes because
I feel that I was not properly advised
at that meeting and something could have
been made part of a particular
application that we now hope that the
developers will be liberal-minded with
shall we say I thank you noted your
comments counselor hoc way but clearly
this is what what what you raised about
inappropriate advice and so on
is in is significant I think possibly
this isn't the venue to discuss this out
fully as it will require some
investigation but I have I have
with the managing director today so he's
aware of today so this will need to be
just for further investigated you happy
at this this point your comment is noted
but it's not actioned until we've had
further further advice thank you write
net declarations of interest next item
number five
that's the merit first we go around a
non-pecuniary interest in item eight
I'm acquainted with the applicant's
father through the Standards Committee
and I and I was also in the past
acquainted with the applicant in a
professional capacity thank you that's
the Wilson non pecuniary interest for
item number seven I know both of the
applicants personally counselor mrs.
Mason
they just like to mention item 7 we all
know who the applicants are yes I think
that's fine obviously it relates to
councillors who are present but will I
believe be disclosing their interest in
due course one appropriate okay yeah
Council mr. hi thank you chairman or
direct pecuniary interest in item 7 as
we are the absent we were I know we
don't have to but we leave the meeting
priority officer report so there's not
too much disruption and come back
afterwards okay now so mr. Mason
okay thank you thank you
right our first item tonight is timber
Grove London Road Raley so sevens are
sort of presentation for us on this one
oh sure I should just mention before we
get started there is an amount of
information regarding applications on
the addendum can I just confirm that
everyone has received the addendum
members I have to adjourn the meeting
because we can't proceed with this item
until councilor Mason is fully aware of
the contents of the addendum so I'll
take five minutes sorry
okay Thank You chair good evening
members I'm just going to take you
through a few slides before I refer back
to the chair so I've got a few slides
and a few photographs and to show you
they'll probably take about ten minutes
to 15 minutes maximum so we'll start off
with the site area the site area being
the red lined area it's very difficult
for me to point here but the this is the
access which is going to be the main
access into the site with the current
access to the timber Grove care facility
being blocked up and that will be s of a
pedestrian access way so in terms of
site dimensions the site is as indicated
in the report is broadly 95 meters wide
at its widest point and it is 265 meters
in length
the word Grove the suggesters exactly
what the niche of the site is is
predominantly as members will see from
that plan towards the north aspect of a
site its consists of law quality
woodland by now which the report
actually indicates as does the amended a
Bora cultural impact assessment it
recognizes that although the site is
subject to a blanket tree preservation
order many of the trees due to
biochemical defects etcetera have and
competing for light really bottom of law
quality trees hence what's made
developments a prospective out to come
up this site really but I'll go on to
speak a little bit about the trees if
required at some later point so that's
the site area it's quite important for
members just to remind members then that
just bear with me I'm just waiting for
stool or duck
'lord up now hmm so over this members
I'm trying to get the next maps of order
we've moved for some reason load up
any suggestions
just bear with me and as I'm trying to
get the system to load up the next image
but there we go yeah not don't click it
often so what members will see there the
the purple area is the SCR one area now
timber Grove been struggling to see this
screen myself from here I'm sorry
timber Grove been in this area down here
so there's just two indicators the
report indicates 71 of the dwellings
will be delivered within the SCR 1
allocation with 12 dwellings provided
outside the SC allocation
just have to be gentle with this machine
I'm afraid mmm just wanted to show you
the location plan yeah we'll try another
slide
just won't do anything listen
stay with me it's not as if it's the
thinking about at the moment is this
it's really bad isn't it
only out slightly out plan I'm sober
this members that's what I can do about
this there we go that's the location
plan right if you see me shaking on this
pen you know why you don't you so
obviously the red site area max out the
extent of the planning application site
members will notice this sort of dogleg
that comes that goes out to a westerly
direction right that's why I guess right
so again that dogleg is shown on this
plan as well like this hopefully that
will stay on the screen right so the
members can see there the extent of the
layout of the site which is quite
important now this plan I'll explain to
members what this plan is that as
explained to a third party an applicant
is not required to show why indicate on
a planning submission the site that
adjoins the planning application sites
or Rochford council has produced this
plan the last couple of days just to
just to demonstrate to members we have
the application site itself then and
what we've done is we've superimposed
Claremont's Avenue I believe it is isn't
it we've plan on present sorry
so we've for the purposes of members
being able to address a particular point
which is that solve within the report on
page six point nine nine of the report
there's a section then twenty four point
one zero up on the impact upon the
amenity of neighboring properties which
is an issue that we'll come to before I
conclude my report so this plan has been
produced to put specifically for that
purpose and what this plan seeks to show
is specifically is the location I'm just
looking to see myself iam sorry members
that this is plot sixteen and this year
is plot fourteen and fifteen and these
are the units for bedroomed
properties in which the assisted living
units replacing the timber Graaf care
facility the move away from the
traditional perhaps institutionalized
type of care this is where these units
are going to be located that's the
purpose of that slide just to show you
so what what members will see from from
this layout is what is quite important
to show is that it's arranged in block
form then the developments obviously
access via these roads the idea behind
this application is what we have here is
the an outline planning consent for the
500 countryside citee which is an
outline consent what we have along the
frontage here is the 49 dwellings at
Grange villa which have been approved
leaving a balance within the SCR one
allocation of one so it's important that
that I think on the outline consent
there's mention and provisions to be
made for sort of integration in with the
phase developments within the talk less
cr1 allocation that's the idea so you'll
see a range in block forms and I'll show
some street views in in in a while but
the important thing to show here is
members will note from the report
there's an 8 metre wide buffer strip
here which coincides with this area at
the top of the site which is there's a
part of it in this area which is flood
zone 2 and then there's an area which is
flood zone 3 so the 8 meter buffer strip
serves three purposes fundamentally
which is one which is to retain a level
of amenity that currently exists on the
site in terms of tree coverage it helps
to slow down water runoff points in
terms there or if block here and also
it's there's a badger set here within
the report there's a badger setter than
to the northwest aspect of a site where
a 10 meter buffer strip has to remain
between any development and the Badger
set so it serves three purposes we'll
move on to the next slide and I'll
just let's have a look
rights okay
right what we'll do is we'll have to
skip a few of these but slightly out
plan relative to yes we've shown that
analysis plan this this plan is quite
useful if it comes up
go on too
it's just potluck this isn't
- knocks all this
see nothing like it really
housing accommodation schedule
right it's okay hmm doesn't seem to want
to open anything I'm sorry remembers
something but that's housing that's an
allocation housing schedule
accommodation schedule I think there's a
number of properties ranging from two
bedroomed as two-story units to have
stories flats all the garages so there's
a range it's just the mind of its own
this has a range of properties types
what this is is the this is quite
important members in accordance with h4
of the of the development plan this plan
actually shows the location of the
affordable housing element within this
scheme so it is sort of stringed out to
within the developments the properties
here they are the three-story properties
these are with hip dhruv's
so inside then basically what we have
here is that is the green space so just
to show that it's not the affordable
housing and not just sort of hemmed into
at one particular corner the site made
up of a range of house types and mixes
really so it won't be obvious where the
affordable housing is within the
developments right let's see if we can
progress
right what I'll might do now is show you
some street scenes because obviously
it's it's quite painful for myself and
members waiting for this machine to load
up so I think it's quite important that
I show you some street scenes really
rather than just block plans that'll
mean more to us I think if we can try
and get these up
it's just really good yeah not you me so
what we have here what we have here is
plot 14 to 16 so I mentioned we'll start
off with those because it's quite
pertinent that we do plots 14 to 16 now
the assisted-living units
ie the timber Grove aspect of the
development and I just like to point out
early so the developed in its entirety
ranges in in built form Heights now what
I'd like to demonstrate to you is is
that these properties here are the
supported living and these were on the
boundary remember the plan I showed you
for the purposes of appreciating where
the site was in relation to claremont
present so just to outline to you the
the massing of this built form here
because that's is a pertinent issue that
subsidy has has been raised now the
height of the building and these are all
reciprocal buildings the same in terms
of design that so there's two there's
two that face north on the plan and
there's one that faces south so arranged
within a the crescents basically now the
height of these buildings are six point
four meters in height to the highest
part of the roof and 2.4 meters to eaves
level so they're being purposely
designed because they are quite close to
the site boundary with claremont
presence there rather than about 3
meters of the site boundary on its
eastern side the eaves levels have been
reduced to 2.4 meters with a hip dream
now you'll see from the addendum that is
concerned regarding impact upon humanity
and i've covered that in 6.99
so just to qualify that point there the
the actual side elevation let's have a
thing now
yes the side elevation saw this this
elevation here is the elevation that
will face the actual highway so this
elevation will be the elevation that
faces east so there's actually no window
in that elevation in any case but I just
wanted to point that out we'll go on to
some street scenes and I think I'll
return back to the chair and conclude
really because I'm let's have a look
street scene 27 yeah
there's nothing open is that all
yeah I can't really speak but open the
slides really to be honest yeah so
in terms of the design and form what I
would say is that from the original plan
members will note that the design has
been amended a number of times the last
design was subject to very consultative
like this end late November and those
designs those designs will work that in
consultation with Essex play services
urban design team so the main focus of
that sort of design review was to look
at getting green edges along the the
highway network to get sort of a like a
boulevard type arrangement where there
was opportunities for planting trees
along the roadway to get Keystone corner
buildings and that's demonstrated in
some of the street views where on corner
buildings you have a building that
actually interacts with both on the
corner of a street so it's it's sort of
a semi curved building look that the
materials
looked at whether the parking on that
area of land which will be blocked
earth-that-was parking for the timber
grow facility previously that's now like
a boulevard walkway pedestrian link so
those are the changes that have been
made we did also consider the the
lawfulness of accepting changes which
are in accordance with the development
management procedure so that is the the
leg out legal so that is covered so what
members will see here this is a typical
cross-section so we're going from from
sort of it's a long section so we're
looking at all the different ranges of
houses along the street scene just to
give members a feel for it would
actually feel like so there are no claw
sport fencing within this development
it's you know there be railings a lot of
brickwork some low walls so reducing any
physical infrastructure that will give
someone impression at the hemmed-in as
they go along the estate role that's
something that the design should avoid
and members will note that the National
Planning policy framework places great
importance on achieving high levels of
design because ultimately these are
places where people are going to live
and neither to high-quality life
are you getting better luck on this Andy
Mike I can't seem to I can't seem to get
it to open anything
in terms of perhaps as this machine this
decided what is going to do in terms of
looking at currently and what I was
trying to show you these slides is
currently then the the road that serves
the really sports and social club
basically that will be the the main
access into the site now in terms of the
the trees themselves most of them as
indicated in the Oracle impact
assessments will be removed over a
phased period it's not doing anything is
this so in terms of the the key issues
that's another street scene perhaps not
sure awesome we can all joy you with us
I'm gonna sort of just maybe sum up what
the key issues are there was lots of
photographs to show you in terms of the
boundary of the site which showed a lots
of trees are on the boundary so in terms
of the development itself most of the
trees will be removed they're subject of
a blanket tree preservation order where
some trees of considered of amenity
value they will be retained the lesser
important trees which are struggling in
terms of the health anyway will be
removed over a period obviously to make
way for the development but the idea is
if members will note that buffer strip
at the north boundary and the northwest
boundary that will be retained which is
part of retaining amenity providing for
the Badger sets and also reducing runoff
from the site so in terms that I'm sorry
that I'm not able to show you probably
there's 50 slides on here members but
I'm obviously unable to show you them
due to the problems so I'm gonna have to
sort of wrap up really but the key the
key issue is is that the housing in
terms of policy then where we stand on
this in terms of housing members well
not from the report in terms of the SCR
1 allocation there's a case that's Roger
Council has a duty to maintain a
five-year land supply so those gone all
over the allocation it's considered to
be given given the the develop that it
is it'll deliver affordable housing it's
not considered to be in conflict with
the council's development plan I would
go as far as to say that the the design
now is exemplar it's it's a very good
design in terms of the spacing and
layout of the development sufficient
walkways green edges along walkways
opportunities for tree planting so it's
a very good scheme in that effect the
there are 45 conditions thing attached
to this consent so in terms of the
safeguards in terms of landscaping
protecting those trees which are to
remain those conditions will achieve
that
the issue in terms of the sustainable
drainage system us as outlined by the
development plan policy DM 28 that's
achieved I think one of the key issues
here is that it's worthy to note that
many people within the consultation
period made comments on the highways
issue in terms as I've acknowledged the
fact that at key times when I've been in
the area the road is very busy there is
congestion etc however yeah so in terms
of the highways issue I have been to the
site on probably five or six different
occasions during the day and I've
experienced as a driver what the site is
like in terms of the site frontage at
busy times of the day now obviously we
sort of you from Essex highways on this
matter and they haven't sort of they
haven't actually indicated a specific
requirements for any sort of highway
provisions that record that they
recognise that there's a that the
developments will cause a further issue
so that's covered there are conditions
within the consents that's in line with
the highways I'm aware that members may
want to discuss the issue of cross
seeing pedestrian cross in safe access
linkage to other facilities etc so in
terms of the flooding then the flooding
is deemed acceptable because it's in an
allocated site the requirements of a
sequential test do not apply your
thoughts in floods on 2 & 3 and the
exception test applies in zone 3 I think
but it does meet with the exceptions
test so as a matter of policy there for
members I consider now the application
having been in with Rochford Council for
quite some time the scheme in terms of
site area is the same but the actually
actual developments the layout of the
developments has changed significantly
with the idea that the
the council and the developer achieves
between them a good quality design that
will serve the community in the future
so on that note I'm apologize for the
slides is quite frustrating having
prepared them I'll return to the chair
thank you have a speaker mr. and good
evening ladies and gentlemen my name is
Scott Clark what you're planning told me
not to come here to put on the
heartstrings of the planning committee
it's a percent technical facts and I'm
actually going to ignore that advice and
one of the things I've always believed
throughout my career as a manager these
people work for people and in turn
people work with people in fact in this
tin instance people are important and so
is freedom of speech I do not need to be
technical I'm not a solicitor in fact
I'm merely a railey resident of over 30
years husband of a Rayleigh
schoolteacher and father to two little
girls aged three and five when I put my
five bed house from Bellway homes two
and a half years ago I thought I'd won
the lottery
in fact I've become mortgaged to the
hilt although we got the dream house in
radiate out in the Rayleigh the town we
used to never want to leave I've gone
through two house moves of renovating
houses to get there I was due a
well-deserved rest in a new build six
months after that arrived the first
version of timber Grove planning
application with a care home sitting
directly bought behind our house and
although the plan has changed many times
the plan you see today is still
unacceptably has a care home that sits
right on top of my 30-foot gardens fence
timber grove marketing a care home
setting two acres of beautiful rural
woodland the first line on the marketing
Fairley of residents have been solved
the dream can I propose a new strapline
care home sitting on top of extremely
unhappy neighbors with no outside space
and no bins for rubbish collection
none of detail than the plants and I
have raised this and had no response to
it I have compared compassion for the
residents of the home but I believe it's
captured security for a reason
think back to the timber Grove the first
line of its marketing why not take the
plans away today and nestled the home at
the back of the development and GU for
the residents of the home the space and
privacy they deserve
indeed fits aways of business not a
charity and is driven by profit not
well-being I also want to see this you
are considering a 24-hour business being
located right next to my house and
neighboring houses staff work covering
24 hours of the day cuts the noise of
staff driving to and from the site car
park which is an awful design by the way
taking rubbish to the hidden bin site 24
hours a day
more noise ambulances turn from the home
more noise deliveries to the home more
noise not to mention the ways for the
residents theirselves not once a fits
for a consulting meet or my neighbors
and what we think of the plans again
people work with people they are working
against potential neighbors already
final fault before I added bits on this
is my original speech review the Essex
design guide and see it's not being
followed asked for a site plan that
shows neighboring properties which has
suddenly appeared last night and make
the right decision and reject me scared
that's proposal for the quote for the
people in this great town I recommend
that due to last night's release of a
site plan of neighboring properties the
decision tonight should now be delayed
to allow comments to be submitted on it
I've been asking for this in fact I will
read out I was I've been told I'm not
allowed to hand this out tonight
yesterday Tim for January a plan was
finally produced that showed surrounding
properties in Claremore Crescent it has
taken 482 days of complaining for the
Planning Department to get its produced
why now the red box on there is my house
why is it why is that there the late
document needs further time for people
to be
less than 24 hours before the
committee's unacceptable therefore I
propose it tonight last night it
appeared on the council website showing
my property highlighted in red I'm not
sure why I have been highlighted in red
and this this doctrine has been my
public thank you this morning 11 for
January the document has now moved
location on the website I appreciate the
website is quite restricted and the
documents are shown it will be funny
with the planned Department of taking it
off for a reason are they trying to hide
it I don't know or to say but I've got
I've got phone shots of from my mobile
phone that state it was on there stating
a tip for January that's when it was
added how can that be acceptable on the
subject of trees it's an interesting one
and I want to at this point and I
haven't got any speech in for this that
that patch of land there behind my house
is the only truce between where my house
is
and London Road we'll see lots of new
houses proposed for that site so why do
we want to take away with air pollution
now being stated as a public health
emergency or always about to be the
stated is that why don't we be take away
the only trees in that area between my
house and the a 130 thank you time do we
have any non members like to speak on
this one
councillor mrs lammle
Thank You chairman I wasn't aware that I
would be called to speak for number
members first and then the members heart
will have their discussion you just get
one go thank you
I understand our residents concerns over
the traffic congestion and pedestrian
safety in London Road I've lived on
London Road for 46 years and experienced
these issues almost every day with
traffic excuse me at a standstill at
peak times in the morning and afternoon
and through to the evening traffic has
difficulty turning right from little
Rita Chase into London Road traffic
queuing to turn right into the BP garage
blocks the main road there are already
too many junctions in close proximity to
this site on a very busy stretch of road
and there will be more the narrow foot
ways are inadequate for pedestrians to
pass someone with a pushchair or
mobility scooter without stepping into
the busy narrow road in this heavily
populated area west of Hatfield Road
junction with Victoria Avenue up to the
carpenter's arms roundabout there is no
safe place for pedestrians to cross the
London Road to access schools and
services over recent years the effects
of cumulative developments inadequate
footways and lack of safe crossing
points together with increased traffic
flow have neither been recognized nor
addressed by highways I'm astounded to
read in the report on page six seven
three para twenty two point one seven oh
that no highway deficiency exists all
incidents that have occurred between
2010 and 2016 are all down to driver
error so that's okay then I don't think
so highways safety for pedestrians and
drivers is a real concern I would just
like to assure residents that
to Essex County Council is responsible
for Rayleigh are actively pursuing the
provision of a pedestrian crossing in
this vicinity and we have a meeting
scheduled with highways in very shortly
I just have one other comment to make
personally and that is around the
secondary school place deficit of 344
places by 2020 to 2026 that's just
around the corner how are these places
going to be provided and where thank you
counselor mr. hi Thank You Trevor you a
brief coming it was interesting to those
I think mr. Davis said he will come back
to the Oracle truly repulsive Rees I'm
not sure you didn't fall and it might be
able to the slide I think there are some
issues around this application and I
think they're probably showing up by the
number of conditions I was reminded by
Tesla mostly 45 conditions may well
suggest there is a problem with the
application there's an awful lot of
conditions relating to the culture and
around a lot of issues around the area
in that also might rent a surface water
drain into conditions it's different
this time I think it's because so that
the application is here at this stage
with those still outstanding
and being put forward as competitions
you thank you just before we go forward
into the members proper discussion you
are quite right counsel hi we have got a
difference in the way that the
recommendations are presented
specifically for this and we did talk
about that a call over wonder if mr.
Evans might just cover the reason why
we've got the full explanation and the
greater amount here please okay to cover
that point where I previously worked
there be 50 60 70 conditions on a
planning consent so it's quite unusual
for heads of terms of conditions to be
included this is for the purposes of a
clarity for members to see exactly in
terms of the conditions that would be
required in any event to achieve the
quality outcomes that come with part and
parcel of development so I would
respectfully respond by saying the fact
that there might be 45 conditions on a
percent reflects actually the complexity
of the application rather than any
difficulty with it that's having dealt
with majors for a long time it's not
unusual to have that number of
conditions whereby it is possible to
show for example certain features on a
plan then government advice does
indicate that where possible conditions
should be at a minimum in order to
reduce the need for pre commencement
conditions etc but my response would be
that for example the suds the suds
the system of drainage conditions are
the conditions on the trees and coming
back to the trees what the abour
occurred a Borah cultural impact
assessment indicates is that the there's
been discussion over probably a two-week
two-year period with the Rochford
district councils of our cultural office
and basically in terms of the conditions
are there to make sure that the that the
outcomes that are outlined in the Abba
Racal impact assessment actually achieve
so the main things we're talking about
there is when a trees to be removed
these etc where now protection barriers
to be put around the trees that are to
remain there for quite some time and
then all the time as the new planting
emerges they will be replaced so the
fact that many conditions on a consent
doesn't actually indicate that there's a
there's a fundamental problem with it
maybe you as an officer would be if
there was a fundamental problem with
this application then the recommendation
is evening would be that the application
be refused however government advice by
the same token does suggest that where
an application can go forward and where
safeguards are required by planning
condition government advise is that it
should go forward with planning
conditions regardless of this 10 or 50
conditions thank you if I just so follow
up so well what essentially we we've got
here is on previous occasions we've had
heads of conditions which you've
described that tree protection as an
example might be in place in this
application we've got the details of
what those protection measures would be
which is one of the principal reasons
why there's so much there which I
suppose is officers having done work
upfront rather than after the the
application has received its permission
or not as the case may be
counts the Mason mr. Mason thank you
chairman oh one last question if I may
we've we've had the benefit of training
on suds which is basically surface water
drainage and because we've had the
benefit of that I'm sure all members
understand the report better but
nevertheless it's a decision of the
flood authority one of the things that I
don't understand and it's a question
is if we have an F ra for this site but
we know there are other sites they're
going to be very close to it if not
adjacent if not adjoining then why don't
we have presumptive potential flow rates
interpolate it into this F ra because
very simply we could agree to this
application based upon the flow rates
that are given and then find that
there's a further development nearby
with a increased flow into that water
course which causes it to flood so what
we've actually done is a Greek to
something without thinking about the
consequences of flow from somewhere else
so my question is where in the
application has that been taken into
account of by the applicant and by the
council and by the flood authority if we
can deal with that one before we get on
to the members discussions can we
I do have the copy of the Fr a and the
hydraulic hybrid hydraulic modeling
analysis so it actually answers your
questions so what the if I can bring it
up on the system just bear with me for a
moment and I'll have a look if I can
find it but an answer an answer in terms
of the hydraulic modeling analysis is
taken into account Florrie so I can't be
categoric and say that it's taken into
account the the floor its that are
coming from other sites like I can't
categorically answer that but in terms
of the modeling has been prepared on the
basis of the response from Essex suds
itself they don't see a problem as long
as it comply with the conditions that
they're set which at which a standard
conditions
so I smoke but I'm not privy to the
finer details of the flood risk
assessment not having read it but I'd
just like to highlight two members and
the concern being about the joint flow
rates when a flood risk assessment is
done on a site the developer has to
calculate the flow from whatever that
site is and what the suds team and the
Environment Agency require is that the
discharge rate from the development
that's before you is either the same or
preferably better than that right so
we've we've had debates in this chamber
about greenfield runoff rights and there
may be tables and it's tabulated and
disputes over the figures but we get to
a point let's say for instance just for
the purposes of this discussion now that
the flow rate is considered as the
society is now without the development
let's pretend 8 liters a second just for
argument's sake what the developer has
to go away with that figure and then do
a scheme and drainage analysis and
everything else tanking holding back
swales so that the scheme that will come
before you either achieves the same 8
liters per second or preferably say
seven seven and a half so there's
improved capacity in the drainage
network now as a broad concept that's
what these developers are aiming to
achieve under the supervision of the
suds team and the Environment Agency so
to some extent it doesn't matter if
there's three or four sites all
adjoining because if they're all
following the flood risk assessment
rules they're all trying to calculate
what the runoff is to start with and
then bettering that through their
development I don't know if that helps
chairman members will now open the
discretionary accounts the mountain
thank you for being so patient
Thank You Sherman 114 pages that was a
quite a weighty read including and plus
the addendum at the end the first point
I want to make it was there is a
correction to the report on the addendum
because the report was initially labeled
as being in Swain Park ward so I accept
that that has been corrected however it
there has a knock-on effect to this the
knock-on effect is on page six point two
six in relation to point twenty one
point four seven it states that there
was no response recorded from ward
members which Ward members were
consulted Swain Park which no longer
exists Swain parking Grange I wasn't
consulted or downhaul in Roth ward I
happen to have direct experience from
previous involvement and engagement
back in 2012 alongside my fellow board
member at the time counselor Joan
moxford she and I attended
pre-submission meetings to discuss the
plans and I find it strange that there
was no response recorded from Ward
members I I'm concerned that Ward
members weren't actually in in invited
to be involved largely because the ward
that was listed no longer exists this
also has a knock-on effect to page six
point four 1.2 1.1 zero 1 where the
Essex County Council economic growth and
development incorrectly make reference
to the site being located in Swain Park
Ward as well so it's not just the actual
front page of the report that needed
amending 0.21 5 for Essex Wildlife Trust
they state they're unable to comment
fully due to difficulties in accessing
the relevant planning documents on your
consultation portal I'm a bit concerned
about that not least because I think
that their involvement would have been
very welcome specifically in relation to
the badges as identified in relation to
environmental impact so it's slightly
concerned there was know that there were
issues with Essex Wildlife Trust they
were unable to access our planning
documents no response from the NHS maybe
it's not necessary to stand out of
interest I think it would be quite
beneficial perhaps to hear from the NHS
in relation to care home provision and
our provisions for elderly residents and
residents and care homes maybe it's not
needed it's just something that I've
flagged up in the hundred fourteen pages
page six point four seven to two point
nine the application site is within the
general location of north of the London
Road policy H 2's er one to accommodate
550 dwellings
this is yep 550 dwellings within SC are
one part the core strategy outline
Planning Commission has already been
granted for 500 dwellings through the
countryside we've had 47 dwellings
through Grange villas so in total if
this site is agreed
ser 1 include these 83 dwellings it will
take up to 630 residential planning
units within the ser one site allocation
not even going to mention the e on site
because I'll accept that was a windfall
however the point is that West
Raley is not to be treated as an area
where we can just have development in a
hotchpotch piecemeal dogleg fashion
without any consideration to how it
affects the residents how it affects
people that travel and live in Rayleigh
and how it affects the look of our
district and what does it state about
core strategy we should have the
confidence and strength as a council to
acknowledge that we identified ser 1 for
550 dwellings not 630 residential
planning units 6.9 2.22 0.279 the
environmental agency have previously
advised that the site is currently shown
to fall within flood zone 3a the high
probability flood zone and is classified
as a more vulnerable development 0.2 to
point 2 8 1 ideally no development would
be provided within flood zone 3a this is
under flood risk mitigation I've heard
mr. Evans
explain the conditions and understand
there are lots of conditions
I also reflect back on member training
that we had with Shan squattin it's
clearly stated that we should be very
skeptical of plans that have several
conditions a number of and this amount
condition now it's not necessarily the
number of conditions that I want to flag
up it's actually what those conditions
are and on I note that on two previous
occasions affordable housing was grow it
was put forward as grounds for refusal
it's now coming under a condition it's
affordable housing is mentioned in a
condition and it just got me thinking
that possibly we should be really really
examining these conditions and looking
through there are 114 page to this
report and wondering whether some of
these conditions aren't actually well
they can't be turned around and
presented as as reasons for refusal
grants refusal for example there is a
lack of surface water drainage strategy
and maintenance plan there is a lack of
any scheme to minimize the risk of
offsite flooding caused by surface water
runoff
and groundwater during construction
works and to prevent pollution there is
a lack of clarity regarding bin storage
collection points in relation to the
apartment blocks there is a lack of
provision of a full landscape master
plan including provisions of play space
there is a lack of a full article survey
and report including a scheme of
supervision for the our be cultural
protection measures lack of material
specification an appropriate samples
providing information relating to
materials detailing and to fixtures and
fittings a lack of submission of a
lighting scheme like a provisions for
well-designed on street parking in
certain areas and concerns relating to
disturbance of badges I would suggest
that as this site keeps coming back and
has been since you know 2012 is the
first time timber Grove was mentioned to
to me on the development meeting in in
development committee
why hasn't developer got this right now
why are these conditions surely these
should be recommendations to the
developer that if you want to get
something approved if you want this to
go forward this is what we as a council
and as a committee expect we need to set
high standards and I have said my say
and I'm very interested to see what
other members have said I may come back
later if that's possible thank you Jim
thank you so Newport now chairman I'll
be brief and I've looked through the
report and page six point 0.42 the
developer should ensure safe walking and
cycling routes to schools
I don't consider there to be any cycling
routes in that vicinity and I'll be
interested to know what the proposals
are for that
as cancer mountains already mentioned
SCR 1 550 houses and this report sells
us on the idea of approving this because
they these how
we'll be built in a timely fashion has a
developer committed to a time scale to
build this site out the other point that
I'd like to brown as cancer Lumley has
mentioned is about the crossing it
recommends in in the report six point
nine five to two point two nine about
the provision of a crossing that could
be sought via a legal obligation or a
condition and that's something that I
would like to see because that road is
not safe it's heavily congested and it's
heavily used by people parents taking
their children to Our Lady of ransom
school and and as you will know yourself
chair the London Road is a very very
busy road at school times the other
thing that's missing from the report
that I didn't see was the details of the
room sizes available and the other thing
that I would like to know if possible
from the officer and the design of the
certs
does that take into account the removal
of the trees is that something that's
factored in with the hydrology yeah
that's it thank you thank you councillor
mrs. Mason thank you Thank You mr.
chairman
I think I can only add to the level of
concern that's been expressed I think
we've got a head and hearts here I've
certainly attended a site visit some
time ago now and have been involved in
the previous applications and we are
aware of the drastic need for improved
housing
for the care home however we are not
here for that reason we're here as a
planning development committee to assess
this application on planning grounds and
I must admit my initial reaction on
reading the report with disappointment I
was disappointed there was no slight
plan I've seen it tonight it would have
been nice to have greater and longer to
look at it though it there is has been
mentioned there's no informational room
sizes it just says the garden size is a
compliant but normally we get a list of
the plot numbers with the garden sizes
so that we can check that we are
comfortable because there have been
mistakes made in the past
not many admittedly but they are made
and that's one of the reasons why
members like to scrutinize detail as
well as the general policies the
schedule for example which we've just
seen up there tonight with without
binoculars it should have been in my
view included however that said I have
two major concerns in addition to the
list of concerns that I've just heard
one of them is this design and access
statement on the design and access
statement there a list of problems no
sight of the Essex Police secured by
design officers report more space
between a standalone unit and terrace of
design room and a terrace which would
have been desirable concern ray a garden
shape that the fact it has no utility
value as a garden missed opportunity to
make the arrival space try arriving
space next to plus 19 and 20 no
information regarding the provision of
play space I mean these are small items
but they should've been dealt with more
importantly on 21 21 I don't know the
page number but there's a list but the
design access statement would like
putting the conditions it's not there
we're talking about the number of 45
conditions in yet something that's
recommended by one of our council T's
unless you can correct me and I have
looked twice but I haven't
it would appear not to be there there's
issues regarding accessing of parking
spaces I mean this is fundamentally if
you provide a parking space and it's
considered that the car can't drive into
that parking space it has no value so
for those reasons the design access
statement I am concerned
my other concern goes to the affordable
housing I think everyone will know I
like affordable housing we need it our
residents need it and 35% is absolutely
fine but 35% of blocks 35% where our
policy I must have misses unclear but
when when we started 35% was if we had a
hundred properties that were three
bedrooms and 104 patrons we would get
35% of each now it would appear the
tendency seems to be that when an
application comes up we get 35% which
being the smallest 35%
unfortunately the details not in the
report it just says two houses not for
sure and 20 what I think's 29 you knew
six houses for shared ownership two
houses for affordable rent and 21 flats
now I believe that's the majority of the
flats are going to the affordable
housing I sipped that we need flats but
we also need houses so look at it
another way
35% if you look at the size for 2-bit
from property we should have one or look
at it another way if you look at the
number of bedrooms that are being
provided across this site taking us
outside the care home it's 199 bedrooms
being kind the amount of affordable
bedrooms that we are providing for our
residents in need a very between 25 and
35 25 and 35 is not 35 percent
and I don't know who decides this or
house decided normally they would be it
would be covered by the housing options
officer and the developer and planning
and consultation and we would have the
detail that detail is again sadly
lacking and I would suggest that we
don't just want one bedroom and two
bedroom properties we also want three
four and five bedroom so that is a
matter of concern no explanation in the
report I'm afraid Thank You mr. chairman
Wilson thank you sure
a couple of questions one is the road
that's going out to the west of the site
in the officers presentation implied
that there was going to be some
connection with the other development is
that the case simple yes or no and my
other question relates to sections
twenty one point one zero one and twenty
one point one zero five at twenty one
point one zero five it stated that a
vice issued if it was the recommendation
of the local planning authority to
refuse the planning application there
lack of childcare and education
provision in the area will constitute a
valid reason to refuse the application
so is that saying that that that's a
very
on the precise point in the report but
what you find with the education
Authority have a misunderstanding of the
appeal process we approach them on this
a number of times they put forward that
there should be some kind of financial
contribution okay and if they find that
the application is refused for some
other reasons they want that financial
contribution to be a reason for refusal
so they get drawn into the appeal
process to defend to the inspector why
they want the money but if members
haven't refused planning permission
because of the lack of an education
contribution which can be secured by
agreement in the applicant is agreeable
they don't get it that it's not a reason
for refusal they they put that caveat in
so that they end up being consulted and
involved in the appeal but as soon as
you got to the appeal the inspector
would turn around and say what you're
doing here
so we have tried to educate them on this
but unless the education contribution
was deemed to be inadequate let's say
education was saying we need so many
million for education or something then
developers not willing to provide it
that's the only circumstances it would
become a reason for refusal they put
that caveat in so that if for other
reasons you refuse it they want that
reason in so they get automatically
picked up and trolled and they don't
lose the opportunity to troll for the
money but if if if it became an appeal
and the inspector was minded to grant
approval he would require the applicants
to enter into a legal agreement to
secure all these things that sit out in
the report hopefully that helps and
finally it's really just an observation
it's a 22-point 1:03
well we're surprised that the language
that was used by six highways which said
that there will be an imperceptible
impact on the local highway network I
actually very rarely go down London Road
I deliberately avoid it during rush
hours but for the last week or so I've
been looking on Google Maps and follow
watching the build-up of traffic and
really it's just to emphasize what
others have said that during peak times
and both in the morning and in the
evening it's either red or amber which
shows that heavy traffic
is there and so I just think adding
extra just discounting it saying it's
imperceptible it's only imperceptible
because you're joining gridlock traffic
and you're not going anywhere either
that's the whole way Anke chairman it's
just one question really the the main
access road that leads into the site is
that also the the main access road onto
the neighboring leisure facility the the
football pitches and all that in that
and once there are issues to do with
parking in relation to usage to those
facilities and how will that affect the
site yeah chairman if it's not our turn
and members will recall one of the
earlier iterations the revised plan that
this this area is currently used as car
parking for the Raley sports and social
club and a separate standalone
application was made to that displaced
car parking to be provided over here so
that is now the subject of a separate
application which is tied in by
agreements to to be achieved so they
have a facility in approval now to cover
the lost carpark in to that access its
that was it if while I'm in chairman
just the point without stealing mr.
Arguelles thunder on the affordable
housing question the point members
raised about why we're seeing a trend
for more smaller units in days gone by
are referred to as the olden days the
housing management would love a
three-bedroom dwelling they can rent it
to a pensioner a single person people
with families is universally adaptable
the problem is now that the people who
would take that tenancy or rent that
unit are penalized for having the larger
units so whilst it might be desirous to
have three bedrooms and be perhaps you
know a single person or just a couple
they can only take the one or two
bedroom units that they need so when
these schemes are put forward the
developers they go to our housing
colleagues
they say what's on your register what's
your demands and needs and the housing
officers tell them we have this many
units in this ward and this many in that
unit and remember the list is fairly
fluid as well because people not only
parked their request with Rochford for
housing but they're probably on basil
dean's list South End anywhere in the
local area so the numbers are somewhat
gray and by the time you come to a
situation of des given a consent some of
those early assumptions in a pre-op
stage have changed but one of the the
common one is that the housing officers
want smaller units because that's the
demand that the people being housed are
going for yes in some cases we see we
want perhaps not know one four-bedroom
unit and however many one and
two-bedroom units because that's what
the list is telling them but that in my
view is why you're seeing a reduced size
of unit in the affordable provision
because the people needing housing are
only being offered those smaller units
because if they if they have it spare
bedrooms that penalizes them counselor
sparing Thank You chairman I think what
colleagues have already raised a number
of issues that I was going to kind of
raise I can't quite comprehend how after
as counselor mounting said for years
we're still going down the road where we
have so many questionable items I have
concern about so many of these issues as
to who is going to be responsible to
make sure these conditions are
implemented there are so many of them
and so in debt that I I am genuine
concerned about that and while this
development is an issue should we say on
its own I have great concerns about the
whole situation is raised by counsel um
Lee and counselor Newport with regard to
the infrastructure of the London Road
we're all familiar with it and just keep
wash our hands of the situation I think
I think somewhere on the line we need to
make sure before anything start else
starts developing on this project that
County reassessed the whole situation
because we know
from our bitter experience in other
areas they just keep saying there isn't
an issue there is an issue and we need
to address it before we perpetuate the
problem Thank You chairman here mrs.
Mason Thank You mr. chairman as you
could guess I'd like to comment on the
officer's comments regarding the
one-bedroom I'm well aware that there is
an excess demand for smaller units
however in this report and I haven't
found it it just says it doesn't say
that there's be no here we are doesn't
say this being the housing office has
been in focuses all we want more
properties and it doesn't give us the
details of the properties that are in
affordable housing so the information is
not in the report and it would appear
from the report that the normal
discussions between the housing options
officers the development planning and
the developer has not taken place
they're not saying it hasn't and I'm not
saying that information isn't available
but it is not clear here there's a
mention about a sanctuary housing
it says fordable housing would deliver a
twenty nine units comprising six houses
for shared ownership two houses for food
were in in 21 flats but in that there's
another area which I can't find and I'm
don't intend to flick through a hundred
and fourteen pages where it just says
preparing options officer says oh yes we
want basically we want more property
well we know that but if if you're
talking about smaller properties then
perhaps we should be took in looking at
thirty five percent of the bedrooms not
of this very small properties so my
point is if you're providing in this
planning application 199 bedrooms across
a mix of properties 35% of that would be
seventy we are actually getting 25
and I wonder we've got very long housing
list if that propensity continues thank
you to come back out the mountain Thank
You chairman I haven't had an answer to
a single one of the points I raised but
I would like to know if any of the
houses are in Greenbelt land any of the
proposed no none okay
well having having not had an answer to
the points are raised I'm going to move
for refusal I'm going to move for a
fusil on the lack of a surface water
drainage strategy a maintenance plan on
the lack of any scheme to minimize the
risk of office it's got a ton of it
slowly the lack of any scheme to
minimize the risk of off-site flooding
caused by surface water runoff and
groundwater during construction works
and to prevent pollution a lack of
clarity regarding bin storage collection
points in relation to the apartment
blocks a lack of provision of a full
landscape master plan including
provision to play space
Donovan's lack of a full are the
cultural survey and report including a
scheme of supervision for the Arbor
cultural protection measures a lack of
material specification and appropriate
samples providing information relating
to materials detailing and to fixtures
and fittings a lack of submission of a
lighting scheme a lack of provision for
well-designed on street parking in
certain areas concerns relating to the
disturbance of Bajor sets a lack of
design access statement that was covered
before and I would also like to feel
that I definitely support the points
made by councillor sparing council only
Casa Newport
however I am worried about adding
anything to do with highways as a
grounds for refusal because in their
infinite wisdom or not Essex County
highways do not raise an objection and I
would caution members perhaps maybe we
have enough grounds for refusal but I
think there is a lack of infrastructure
I think there are concerns of
infrastructure and if if other member
another member it could could phrase
that I would support that but I'm
reluctant to put anything forward at
this stage thank you
if I might the site used to be some of
it used to be in the Greenbelt that
changed when the bulk of the site was
allocated into ser 1 but the area at the
bottom of the site where the care home
stands is in a former allocation of
community use in the old local plan so
not all of the site was fully within ser
1 there was a proportion of it which was
not in the Greenbelt previously and then
the balance of the site was changed from
green belt to SCR 1 that's why 10 or so
of your units are not in the SCR one
area that it spreads over the existing
careful 9 and into what was previously
green belt if that makes it clear Jim
second cancer Mountain I think I counted
9 sort of general areas obviously some
of those officers will have some views
on on some of those and the the strength
of them or not as the case may be I
think it's probably best if we just go
through each one in turn that you hear
the office of viewpoint before you ask
for a seconder if that's okay so if we
can get an idea of how this going but we
if we're going to ask the officers in
turn to do a job we need to be have the
clarity so if we if we keep focuses so
we're on surface water runoff and issues
around that in the first instance I've
noted conditions 17 in the report can we
just take the office of you on surface
water runoff please
right till that that aspect has been
partly answered by the officer here in
terms of the suds element mrs. Frank's
is right to say that any scheme needs to
demonstrate that the the the water
runoff from a site is no greater
following the development as what it is
currently I have to say I'm very
frustrated tonight members by the fact
that I'm unable to show you these slides
because at the end of the day if you're
able to see most of these slides most of
these questions that have been answered
so from my point of view it's highly
highly frustrating I've prepared for
significant time of these slides and
obviously hasn't worked out there will
deal the questions in terms of suds that
is the situation I would like to I have
checked actually on the system you may
have noted that I bought up the
hydrological modeling report on the
system the header of it now in terms of
the documents that been submitted I'll
come on to that hydrological modeling
report I can actually verify in terms of
comes to Mason's question I've checked
that report on here as we were the chair
was taking questions that actually the
modeling is across the whole flood zone
so it does take into account all of the
adjacent sites as across the actual
flood zone area of the 'really area so
in terms of that modeling it is related
to the suds aspect so in terms of suds
what we have is is igano-kun is an
acknowledgment from Essex County suds
that's given certain safeguards which is
normal practice in the events of
assessing and delivering at developments
that there will be conditions that
actually tie the developments in
accordance with the modeling and the
rationale that being set out clearly in
the modeling analysis that's my first
response to the first question okay
I've written down 14 questions chair so
I just want to keep the clarity here so
are you happy to continue with that one
as as a reason can you just well that
there is it is clearly stated there is a
lack of strategy and maintenance plan
as well so good just I'm just making it
clear so you're going to move
can you just restate that element your
recent reason for refusing one of my
grounds for refusal is a lack of surface
water drainage strategy and maintenance
plan okay thank you so with that that's
that's one in the bag
second one I had was a round bin storage
if we dealing with that one please if I
was able to show members the slide the
bin storage is shown on this plan which
is an excuse I lighted on the in the
report as well another it's a - skill
drawing but the report says that the bin
storage areas will be in the curtilage
of each property so they're highlighted
in blue on this plan so opposite every
property there's a bin storage of
typical green wheelie bin there's not
going to be any sort of commercial
really bin storages even for the the
assisted-living units they're just small
thin collection areas adjacent to each
property this is clearly shown on this
plan so the officers are saying that the
plans show that bin storage is
demonstrated how do you want to go with
that one what the the plan doesn't show
is it there's still a lack of clarity
not regarding bin storage but collection
points in terms of problems of access so
I'm still keeping lack of clarity
regarding bin storage collection points
in relation to the apartment blocks as a
grounds to refusal thank you Tim next
one I'm going on to is landscape and
play space please
don't make a comment on that one
a landscape master plan has been
submitted and support the application
now what the plans clearly show as I
indicated in the at the outset despair
when I need to find my pen is you can
see from the plan green areas at the top
of the site at the northeastern corner
of the site that's a green area and
specifically the design that's been
worked up in accordance with Essex
County Council urban design is is to
concentrate on getting green spaces
green edges for the sides of the highway
etcetera so there's no allocated
playground as such but there are green
amenity areas within the development
both in terms of at the top end of the
site and also there's that Boulevard
walkway which is the current access to
timber grove facility okay okay okay
restate and reconfirm whenever I walk
around the old Eon site I smile as I
look at the play space because I first
moved for that to be refused as a
grounds there wasn't a play space so I
think that there is if we are looking at
families moving into the area I think
there is a desire for a play space to be
included with any plans so I will stick
to my grounds for refusal lack of
provision of a play space thank you
thank you next one the scheme of
supervision around sorry can you tell me
that it was so the next one was that the
lack of a full oberek yep that one arbor
cultural survey and report including a
stance right the over cultural scheme
supervision please right that is not
maturely the case there has been a
revised that bore a cultural impact
assessments submitted in November
and this is an extract from it it
details very clearly the trees are
bitter it removed details the phasing of
the developments details trees to be
crowned it's a lot to read but it is all
there so the in terms of the actual
requirements are set out in the AIA as
we call it it is all there and the
conditions reflect that the the details
of the tree removal scheme given the
fact there is a blanket tree
preservation order it recognizes that
some trees are to be retained they are
shown on a tree retention plan which I
can't show you because the IT issues so
all that information is there and that
has been agreed with the council's a
Borah cultural impact officer so it is
the information is there for us to make
a judgment on thank you thank you
Thank You chair okay that's fine I it
wasn't in the report I'm basing my
reasoning on what is in the report I
accept what the officer said and I will
remove that as a grant feasel thank you
next one got around materials fixtures
and fittings within the properties
the the streets elevation plans the aim
of those are over table to show you that
all of them was there's a mixture of
brick render so that is a depiction of
the actual materials however it's not
unusual as a sort of condition two or
three to standardize the conditions in
terms of reference to the plan so
there's two ways of safeguarding what
the development in terms of materials
are used it isn't I noted the comments
the member made about vetoes on
materials it would be standard to
condition the plans in accordance with
the submitted plans the plans indicates
the type of finish but then there would
be condition on the submission of
details of the material finishes which
isn't unusual as a condition so the
issue about the materials are going to
be used and the lack of clarity there is
clarity in the streets elevations
however I do accept that further clarity
is required that clarity in certainty
would be would be required unsafe
gathered by your a condition did you
point out which condition that might be
as possible
the mountain on that one
I've heard what the officers had to say
I'm happy for that to remain as a
condition as opposed to grounds for
refusal
should we get around lighting I've got
next lighting scheme wasn't it that's
correct it is down as condition seven
and eight but there is a lack of
submission of a lighting scheme okay in
terms of that I think at the end of the
day in terms of it I think that can be
addressed by your condition so prior to
the first installation of any lighting
scheme it has to be submitted if we've
been writing I don't see a reason as to
in planning as to why it has to be
submitted now so I accept there was a
lack of explicitness about that
situation however it's a standard that
could be addressed by condition and
resolved before the first installation
of any lighting scheme
followed up with is the fact that early
the developers should have got this
right by now this been going on since
2012 but I accept that it can be made of
conditioning if we were talking about
approval that would be a condition yes
next one I've got is design of all off
street parking or on street parking
yes in terms of the in terms of the
layouts this was a matter that was
raised by Essex County Council urban
design so in terms of the layout that
members see before them now in terms of
the rods the rods have been designed in
terms of the geometry to ensure that Ben
lorries can maneuver within the site and
also these sort of offshoots from the
main sorry
these offshoots if I can see them from
the main access road the design and its
entirety now has taken into account the
the geometry and the turning areas that
are required by Ben wagons to touchy
maneuver and turn within the site so
members are north that I mentioned about
the the high quality designers path the
National Planning Policy framework
within that consideration it's obviously
we acknowledge it's not what the houses
just look like it's to do with
everything isn't in its entirety and we
acknowledge that in order to be
adoptable in the long term once it's
completed then it has to comply with
parking standards and turning parking
and serving areas for for long vehicles
as well thank chairman I'll keep that as
a grants refusal like a provision for
well-designed on street parking in
certain areas thank you okay thank you
budgets next
yes so in terms of I would like I would
like to clarify that in terms of the
documentation that has been indicated
hasn't been submitted the documentation
is all there
there are various documents this is the
ecological impact assessment that was
submitted and basically in a nutshell
what the assessments does is one of many
things it assesses what the impact of
the construction period itself will have
on Badger sets so Badgers are protected
and the wildlife and conserve act 1981
and also by separate badgers act so in
terms of the buffer zone for badges that
is the reason for the 10-meter buffer
area because the badge is what's
happening apparently is that the Badgers
there's about ten sort of holes entrance
points the set here and they tend to be
traveling out into the plowed field here
and across to the the sports and social
club area that are all around so in
terms of impact on badgers this report
is a quite a weighty document that's
actually taken into account the
conservation status of badges and what
effect that the development would have
and it covers things from mitigation
during construction period two to
safeguards you know once the development
is is actually assessed and in terms of
just clarifying the issue there in terms
of the Essex Wildlife Trust that
difficulty in accessing the information
what we have is a is a sort of a non
objecting response from natural ingre
England so they've actually have got no
issue with the development and given
their statutory obligation to comment on
any impacts upon wildlife then I have to
conclude on the basis of this report and
the recommendations made in within this
report that Badgers will not be
adversely affected during the course of
developments are thereby afterwards and
I've taken the guide from this report
and also natural England's response to
inform my report on that one thank Joan
two point two two point two one eight
there will be an increase in the levels
of noise and visual disturbance during
the construction phase which have the
potential to result in disturbance to
the retained badges set it's in the
report
so I mean slightly contradicts what the
officer said it's okay I mean it clearly
is going to disturb the badges
the the acknowledgement is in this
report that there will be disturbance
but it won't affect their their status
you know they the the set if the set was
going to be removed and bulldozed away
but the set is going to have a fence
around it during the course of
development it's not so indicating that
the Badgers will all remain perhaps they
will get disturbed but in its entirety
that set isn't actually not being
interfered with in terms of its of being
bulldozed and basically on the basis of
this report it's there's obviously going
to be some impact but not impact that's
actually going to affect their favorable
conservation status and that is actually
the response that's aligned with natural
England's response trying to take a
position on that item then in or out
see
okay okay and the last one of my list is
design and access statement around the
donut on an access statement yep my
response to that is that the designer
Maxis statement obviously is he's
talking through the application I wasn't
quite sure the point that comes the
Macon Mason was was making the items it
all depends also which designer Maxis
statement has been submitted there's
been an amended designer access
statement that was submitted as the last
complete set of amended plans that was
submitted in November but I'm not sure
what was the actual point that comes to
me can chance the mountain on this so
sorry yes forward updates report in
November I will I think we have
sufficient grounds for refusal as they
are I will are you content that we've
gone through your items thoroughly right
okay at this moment in time members we
have five reasons for refusal that have
been put forward by counts the mountain
around surface water runoff being
collection play space the quality of
provision of our off street parking and
the budget set is anyone willing to
second that counts the Newport right
members we have a motion for refusal on
five points that have been clearly
clearly explored and discussed I think
it would be wrong to bring anything new
and everyone's had the opportunity to
discuss prior to that so I will ask for
a vote now so those members in favor of
refusal based on the five points that we
put forward and discussed and had the
clarity over please indicate
okay those against that item is refused
thank you for your perseverance on that
one members yes and that's the cut more
I'm not very interested in that debate
and following it thoroughly one thing
that comes to light is the fact that
there are certain items that have been
raised by the local board members that
don't seem to have been discussed or
collaborated with by officers and I have
concerns about that I think the idea of
the whole idea of this is that officers
should work with Ward members as to how
they complete the designs I need'd the
ward members are saying they weren't
even in consideration in some of the
items there so I'd like to get some
clarification on that chairman I think I
just finish what I'm saying well I think
mine can stack up more I think the way
in which the planning committee works is
not four or so with the development
committees not for the development
committee to discuss we simply need to
take the applications that are presented
for us and come up with the decisions I
mean but it was in German and the end
isn't the right one and that's the
problem it is but your point is noted
and that will be taken to the
appropriate venue and I think you're
probably in the best position to
determine what that venue would be right
our next item item 7 3a be closed home
bridge counselor mr. and mrs. hoy have
left of the room would anyone like to
say anything on this this was up
obviously wouldn't normally come before
us
I will chairman I'm hopeful that the
plans will kick in in a moment this is
on the to a semi-detached house on the
western side of every close 15 metres
north of the junction without B Road we
can see the proposed plan there and our
loan because about problems with IT
tonight I'll only dwell on the existing
plan the application is for a part two
Story part single story side extension
you'll see from the floor plan that it
extends out to attach on to an existing
ground floor rear extension and as the
chairman said it's brought usually
delegated type application but brought
tonight before members because the
applicants are members of this council
the extension width is two and a half
meters overall but reduces down by a
meter as your guidance requires for a
suitable side isolation space at upper
floor level then you'll see that it is
roofed over so that we reduced the
amount of flat area concerns it'd be
finished in matching materials to match
with the existing house you'll also see
they've the designer has taken in a
subservient form by putting it just a
slight drop of 0.15 meters at the ridge
line just to make it look like an
addition as opposed to a over
enlargement of the dwelling itself the
layout would retain two car parking
spaces in the front garden area and
accordance with your standards there is
an issue that's not to material but to
point it out to members just to be
thorough that the rear elevation you'll
see there's an extra window at the back
here because it's in the same plane as
the existing windows and therefore
overlooks the garden the same the
neighboring gardens the same as the
existing windows just albeit a bit
closer although there would be that
slight increase and that's what it is a
slight increase of overlooking it's not
material it wouldn't amount to a
reasonable reason for turning the
application down and similarly you'll
see at first of all level there are two
side windows one to a bedroom and one to
a walk-in wardrobe they face a solid
brick wall there's no windows to number
one alongside that would be in close
proximity and an overlooked so the
recommendation chairman as you'll see in
the report is for approval subject to
the conditions in the officer report
members move the recommendation for
approval from the chair as made members
in favor of the approval please indicate
unanimous thank you
item 8 for cage filled cottages stand
Bridge Road stand bridge again this is
one that wouldn't normally come before
us as presenting on this one mr.
strengths is doing this one again I am
chairman we just lost some stones
temporarily
this this app chairman this application
is to a semi-detached house located on
the eastern side of Standridge road 35
meters south of the junction Maywood kg
road in the village of sap of stand
bridge which is residentially allocated
although it's surrounded by by the
Greenbelt the proposal is for a small
front extension when we see it in a
moment to the porch and the bathroom
attached on the side and this item is
brought before you because the applicant
is closely related to an independent
member of the Council standards
committee the proposed extension would
project forward of the original wall by
one and a half metres and would have an
overall width of four point one meters
we can see it now on here this is the
small projection on the front you'll
notice the existing bathroom on the side
and members will know hopefully they can
see that the roofing that goes over the
front will again come over the back of
the existing addition on the side to
which it attaches it extends the
bathroom extend to the porch route will
roof over so there's no less unsightly
um flat roof forms there's no windows as
you'll see giving rise to overlook in
and it's finished would be finished in
matching materials it would retain
two-car parking spaces in the front
garden area which I'll compromise by
this and therefore it's recommended for
approval
just just one point before members
decide there is a listed building some
distance over here the former old post
office it's deemed as you'll see in the
report that the distance between that
and the proposal would not be
detrimental to the setting of that
listed building so as I said earlier
chairman the recommendation is approval
subject to the conditions in the report
recommendation members printed on page
eighteen three move the recommendation
those members in favor of the approval
please indicate cute that's unanimous
that's approved item nine which is
referred application from whisky with
weekly list how house your Park Falls
Lane home bridge additional access surf
holiday park into Kingsman Farm Road
mrs. Frank's is taking this one I
believe
chairman whilst we wait for that one to
warm up this is to a site at the far end
of Paul's line where it joins with
Kingsman Farm Road the site as you're
hopefully see in a moment is to a
holiday and residential caravan park
Paul's line runs into the site here the
existing entrance comes in to a central
point with a little roundabout in sight
office and in this part of the site is
the predominantly residential uses which
are on the higher ground of the site the
remaining balance of the site generally
is laid out or will be laid out for
holiday caravan type uses now the
application before you is for a new
second access point at this point here
off this this line which is your C is
predominately single track and members
at site visit saw that is substantially
overgrown on both sides which we
significance later on there's a ditch
along this side which means that the
issue the crossing here would need to
culvert that ditch I don't know if we
can stand a chance of getting on the
first the point being chairman that has
initially proposed and hopefully I'll be
able to demonstrate it to you the the
pipe had a limited court limited
diameter and the Environment Agency
objected to the Culver ting of that pipe
because they were frightened it
obstructions and general flows in in
times of flooding would dam back because
it because of that and if the machine
will help us I'm hoping it will just
show you the diuretic because the real
detail is in the next one if it's not
gonna play ball can we switch to the
second one and then
we get one of them hopefully now what
the applicant did in response to the
objections he went away and altered the
design and what we'll see in a moment is
that the net area standard the if I can
show you here imagine you've got a round
pipe which was found unacceptable the
applicant altered the design liked it
more like a letterbox more like a box
and that's the good one it whilst this
is up if members try and visualize that
area there which is the section through
the ditch without the development the
revised detail which is now recommended
to approval for you this kind of net
area is more or less equal and that's
why the Environment Agency no longer
hold their objection the design of the
culvert has been broadened more like a
letterbox as opposed to a pipe so that
the flows that were of concern to the
Environment Agency can pass through and
on that basis on this revised plan the
Environment Agency removed their
objection now members will see from the
details that the highway authorities is
consulted on the merits of the
application this involves an access and
various difficulties with the strengths
and what the highway authority have
reported back to us is that whilst
normally the ambient speed on this road
could be up to 60 miles an hour because
that's the national speed limit for that
type of carriageway the conditions on
this stretch of road are so poor that
actually drivers will be going at a very
slow rate now that actually works in
favor of this scheme from a highway
point-of-view they say that the the
ambient speeds that will be traveled
along this stretch support because the
vehicle is gonna be moving so slowly
there's more room for drivers to react
and maneuver and therefore they raise
now objection on on highway grounds
there are a number of conditions that
are recommended to that such as
improvements to visibility to the
hedgerows etc to do with that but this
is
I was going to use and I'll use it now a
surprising recommendation because as
drivers when we look at the site we
conscious of it and that's the very
point that the highway authority are
making the sign that we're so conscious
of the fact that the access is in a
tight visibility it's a narrow road that
psychologically the drivers will slow up
and therefore they are raising no
objection on highway safety issues to
you so the recommendation chairman as
you'll see in the report is one of
approval subject to those conditions
there is one letter on the addendum
you'll see from the applicants agent I
won't read it out because members have
seen it but say the recommendation is
approval thank you mister hoi believe
you wish to speak Thank You chairman
well that's really impossible but we
will say this was called in and there
was a site visit which M I believe three
members attended which are slides
appointed because I think attending the
site would have helped members
understand the points I'm going to raise
I think the best speech would be the
number two actually I would like to
every I'm going to say much better I
would also like to call it upon the fact
that our officers earlier mentioned
about educate educating Essex we've got
education perhaps we need to educate
Essex with regard to highways as well
our draw members attention to point 15
on page nine point one point five the
highways issues which has already been
alluded to the site of the proposed
access would be to a relatively narrow
stretch of road and where the visibility
is poor because of alignment and the
substantial hedging on either side of
the line as said the Pearlie Essex
highway stinks that will make people go
slower further round or not immediately
lost the point I want to make they
suggest and I cannot find enough because
I've turned the page though they're easy
Jim is on the same page that there would
only be anecdotal evidence for my side
of the story which i think is dangerous
still however I'd like to point out that
Essex highways don't even have anecdotal
evidence they have no evidence this is
just their view their view is that
because this is a narrow road and its
people will therefore be traveling
slowly this is a residential Road where
doesn't like it as a large number of
houses further down and people who use
this road live on this road they are
used to it and they or they will be
driving far faster than people who do
not know the road shall we say this is a
site to a holiday camp caravans on the
bend the the site of the entrance is
immediately on the left of this
photograph where that the green is on
the right sorry
get my deck the person coming out will
be there head would be roughly where the
ditches and they're looking up that road
round a bend which is a few yards
further to their right where cars will
be coming around that bend and they'll
be putting out into the road without
being having a clear sight around the
bend I think it's only two meters the
hedges will be removed there was talk
about locking the oak tree I think is
I'm not very good on trees the big tree
in the middle of the picture on the
lower branches I I'm not sure what lower
branches they they mean because to me
it's the hedges which is in the way
rather than the tree i I I believe this
should be refused on the grounds of the
fire ways the it's a dangerous entrance
there is no clear line of sight for
drivers coming exiting the site the
drivers exiting the soil joining the
site will not be used to the road
because they would be visitors the other
people use the road will be residents
who will be driving faster
then people who would not know the road
which may well be Essex highways
I've asked if Essex highways have
actually visited to the site I haven't
had a confirmation that they have so I
would ask members to to consider this I
know we are told we have to obey what
Essex highways tell us but I really do
think that times they haven't paid for
the tension to the issues on these sites
thank you any other move are visiting
members wish to speak on this item right
counselor mounting them please Thank You
chairman it's a holiday park sorry I
just wonder are they all static homes or
would there be an expectation that
perhaps caravans or or vehicles with
trailers etic there it's all static so
there would be no caravans entering that
this site if if Essex highways are
convinced the vehicles are driving
slowly around there then surely they
would have no objection to reducing the
speed limit councillor mrs. Mason Thank
You mr. chairman as you're probably
aware I didn't get on the site visit
because I wasn't on this committee
however when I read this report prior to
this evening I couldn't see a problem
currency problem at all so I actually
went and visited the site and I don't
know who the members were that on the
site busy but I was surprised at the
severity of the band and I was standing
roughly slightly further down I think
where they proposed access is my car
came round the corner towards us and I'm
not good judge of speed but it was I had
to move out of the way quite quickly and
I couldn't see it and I didn't hear it
to be fair
there's another Bend on the other side
it's between two pens but this bender is
shown here I would say is that
potentially the most dangerous I'm
concerned that we don't know if Essex
County Council had visited the site
I understood the protocol was that they
would explain that they would inform us
if they had and if or what if they've
done a desktop analysis certainly from
my experience looking at it on paper
yeah not problem looking at it on the
ground yes there is a problem it in my
view it's potentially dangerous we've
sought clarification about whether
they've visited the site and
unfortunately that that clarification
hasn't come just that we haven't had an
answer not the notice one way or the
other
however just to reiterate Essex County
Council have put their formal decision
on page 20 point to 2122 councillor cut
more very briefly chairman I think we're
in the same clef stick as we are with
other applications in as much as if you
actually took this to Appeal County
Council would would have no evidence and
you'd lose your appeal so whilst I
accept that there may well be problems
with this particular site and I think
the the carry is quite right to clarify
them I think unfortunately we're in a
position where we have to accept it they
want Chancellor Wilson Thanks chair and
I'm very familiar with this area and
anecdotally when I was out delivering
leaflets in 2016 and 2015 I was totally
taken out by cars that came around the
bend there they come round faster than
you think and the the photograph there
is shown a winter or autumn there were
no leaves on them now the paradox is
that in summer when all the leaves are
on the trees it's actually very dark way
so you can't see the vehicles coming out
the current entrance and exit to the
site is actually in an ideal position
because you can see it approaching from
either directions it's actually very
clear what's going on and my concern
here
is that the vehicles that are coming out
of here if you turn left into Kings mums
farm road and go down to the brandy hell
that's probably not where most of the
traffic is going to be going they're
gonna be turning right and what my
concern is the danger that you can't
actually see vehicles approaching you
coming out the shadows in the summer
thank you thank you chairman I just
wondered these is there any prospect to
defer this to seek further information
from Essex County Council I think as its
County Council have put their viewpoint
and I'm quite happy that we've got more
than enough information to make a
decision tonight accounts the mountain
Thank You chairman I was cancer hurt way
beat me to it but I think in terms of
what what Casa Carmel said again we are
we're right we're in the situation we we
can't I cannot with these concerns that
are being voiced by members and I can't
have with a clear conscience support
this application because if it's
supported and there's a horrible road
traffic accident or whatever I'm not
going to be the one that moved for
approval but I I know what the chairman
has said pretty sure what you said but
there are sufficient members concerns
here I am going to move for this to be
deferred requiring further based on
members concerns we are not having all
the information we require from Essex
County highways when did they visit the
site there's there's lacking information
so I'm moving for this to be deferred
subject to the receipt of further
information can I ask before before we
go to that so we're seeking the whether
Essex County Council visited the site or
not we are seeking the confirmation of
the Essex County Council position it is
up to them we cannot demand them to
visit the site they need to just
reiterate or not their position we will
make it clear that
the reason behind our request is it is
unclear whether the our visited site or
not but we are our request in the
deferment is to ask Essex County Council
to reiterate to their position or modify
it as appropriate on grounds of safety
correct because it's we possibly I'm
speaking out here but believe it's
inappropriate to have a turning on a 60
mile speed limit in this location did
you want a second that okay so well I
think rather than continue the
discussion if we've got a motion for
deferment I think we might as well just
dealing with that rather belonging the
discussion tonight so are on the base
assists that Essex County Council will
be asked on on the grounds of safety to
reiterate the position or not as the
case may be those members in favor of
the deferment on those grounds please
indicate that item is deferred hopefully
they can come back next month and we'll
have that right members thank you very
much for your perseverance tonight
meeting closed